mis seis aviones tres helicópteros
159 brigadistas y todo el personal de
apoyo convocado por el servicio
argentino de manejo del fuego logran
contener los incendios forestales que
azotan las provincias de corrientes y
misiones desde enero por lo que el
gobierno pidió ayuda a estados unidos
brasil y bolivia y corrientes llama la
atención de toda la argentina obviamente
acaba de vivir una tragedia corrientes
tenemos puesto todas nuestras fuerzas
para ayudar porque la argentina es una
no hay una argentina de accidentes en
argentina periférica no hay pueblitos y
ciudades hay argentinos que necesitan de
que la argentina se levante
más de 600 mil hectáreas ya fueron
consumidas por las llamas entre los
argentinos hay especial preocupación por
las plantaciones de yerba mate crucial
en su dieta que se encuentran en
corrientes paraguay que limita con esa
provincia argentina también se ha visto
afectada por el fuego este país el
cuarto exportador de soja en el mundo
advirtió que la cosecha puede disminuir
hasta un 60% este año eso significa
aproximadamente entre 2500 y 3000
millones de dólares menos que no van a
ingresar a nuestra economía los
productores de carne también temen que
la escasez de pastos genere cuantiosas
pérdidas entretanto las autoridades
alertaron que la calidad del aire es
crítica en asunción por lo que el
ministerio de salud recomendó permanecer
en el interior con puertas y ventanas
cerradas